now we've heard a lot about the term
court packing
right i remember this from eighth grade
history when
fdr that's when i heard about it 1937
yeah
yeah in fdr he maybe i guess he was
frustrated in the same way
many presidents are when the court
doesn't rule in their favor
so he wanted to add justices it was look
it looked like a power grab
but then in this recent run-up to the
controversy
we've learned that well it's not
unconstitutional right
no i mean the constitution does not say
how many justices there have we could
have a hundred we could in fact we
started with six and then went down to
five and then six and then seven and
then nine and then ten
down to seven and then his girlfriends
in the later years
it's a whole other story um but uh
but um we've been at nine since 1869 and
again all it takes is
like a lot of things to change our
government all it takes is an act from
congress to change the number and so the
proposal is to give
four more additional justices to make it
13. but that would
look like a peregrine not that they
don't kind of deserve it because
of the way mitch mcconnell and the
republican congress
completely [ __ ] the democrats in a way
that was completely unprecedented
when they wouldn't well that's i mean
i kind of i mean i don't like the idea
of politicizing the court on the other
hand
that is one of those things that like
cannot stand
that they denied a president a pick
because that's fundamental rules you
broke the fundamental rules when you
break the fundamental rules
and it goes back to the ideas like why
do we have a court with lifetime
appointments you know the original
intent was to make it so it's really
non-partisan that's not in there
either what in the constitution lifetime
appointments is in the comments
that is that isn't the concept right but
the idea is to have it be these
unelected people whose allegiance is to
the constitution and to federal laws and
so having this sort of
you know even-handed balanced court is
is kind of core to the whole
original idea
you